good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-1472 chlid
special containment procedures all
mobile devices that have a CP 1471
installed are to be confiscated and
analyzed for any potential leads to
other possibly affected devices
afterwards affected devices are to have
their batteries remove be assigned a
designation for example SCP 1471 then a
number and be placed in storage unit 91
at research site 45 all online
application stores for mobile devices
are to be monitored to prevent any
inadvertent sales of scp-1472 spected
devices are to be targeted using self
uploading malware in order to disable
the device until it can be seized by
field agents description scp-1472
ideation for mobile devices named mallow
version 1.0.0 in online application
stores scp-1472 listed developer and is
somehow able to bypass the application
approval process to go directly to
distribution scp-1472 avoid removal by
another program manager applications
after a CP 1471 is installed no icons or
shortcuts are created for the
application as CP 14 71 will then begin
to send the individual images through
text messaging every three to six hours
all images will contain a CP 1471 8
either within the background or
foreground as CP 1471 a appears as a
large humanoid figure with a canid like
skull and black hair
during the first 24 hours following the
installation of scp-1472 mobile device
will receive images taken at locations
commonly frequented by the individual
after 48 hours the mobile device will
receive images taken out locations that
were recently visited by the individual
after 72 hours the mobile device will
receive images of the individual in real
time with scp-1472 in close proximity to
the subject individuals with more than
90 hours of exposure to these continuous
images will begin to briefly visualize
scp-1472 their peripheral vision
reflective surfaces are a combination of
the two continued exposure to scp-1472
this point will cause irreversible and
sustained visualizations of a CP 1471 a
individuals at this stage have reported
periodic attempts made by a CP 1471 a to
visually communicate with them but fail
to understand or comprehend these
actions currently the only known
treatment to reverse scp-1472 fact is to
eliminate the individual's visual
exposure to these images prior to 90
hours after installation to date no
apparent hostile activity has been
reported regarding a CP 1471 a and this
is archival document 1471 one note
scp-1472 don application stores malo
version 1.0.0 free zero reviews
description for three never settle for
those awkward feelings of being alone
ever again Malo is an exciting and
interactive experience that will keep
you engaged and intrigued the anxiety of
social situations can be nerve-wracking
but after just a few hours of Malo
you will soon forget about all those
painful emotions of disappointment be
part of a new craze that is quickly
becoming the next social substitute
member the more you participate the more
Malo will engage you your experience is
completely up to you absolutely no ads
enjoy addendum 1471 one this is the
experience of William reconstructed in
audio format by acid the on-site AI
playing reconstruction now I was scared
my first song it happened just as you
told me the messages the pictures seeing
him around every corner afterwards I was
so young who wouldn't have lost it
Williams side by then he was over the
creature following him it wasn't like it
was going to go away no matter how much
he begged or pleaded or attempted to
bribe he knew that the best and only
solution would be to just get used to
Capone being there at least he had the
solace of knowing that he wasn't going
insane believe me William I know many
people have reacted the same way
fear is a more common reaction to the
unknown than you'd think dr. Laura
brain's consoled him his cases weren't
exactly common but they were commonly no
it's not even that I'm afraid anymore I
mean he makes me jump when I see him in
the morning I don't think I'll ever get
used to that it's just the bad
connotations he has William rebutted I
know that he does but it happened two
years ago I know it's hard for you
especially with your shadow but you need
to carry on
dr. brain stated William just sighed as
she continued our session is almost up
we made some real progress William I
want you to do something for me when you
get home do you have any homework or
anything I did it all on my break good
when you get home I want you to think
back to your first experience write as
much as you feel comfortable sharing is
that Alright
yeah Thanks for seeing me it wasn't too
long a drive from the doctor's office to
home five possibly ten minutes if there
was a train he always saw the creature
through the rear view mirror when he
drove riding in the back seat it looked
innocent in its own alien way waving to
William as he saw it despite everything
William found himself talking to it like
one would talk to a dog or a can about
their day when they're alone it seemed
to listen when he talked and after a
while he could swear that it understood
it's hard to tell him with a face like
that so all there were to go by and were
various head tilts and waves and even
then he had to teach it how to wave at
least I know you're interested drop the
backpack near the door go to the patio
wave to Capone from the mirror fridge
drink chair crash Williams afternoon
routine was more clockwork than it
should be he thought back to his session
with dr. brains she wanted me to try and
recapture the experience when I first
saw him huh
William mumbled as he grabbed a few
sheets of paper and a pen bit by bit
he pieced together the sequence of
events that lead up to this point I've
had Capone with me ever since I was 15
years old I remember that my 20 year old
sister Sarah brought up an app that she
downloaded earlier at the dinner table
one night she had no idea how it does it
but hazarded a guess that it tracks you
through your phone's GPS and sends you
pictures of the places you've been with
a really cute monster placed in the
photo to make it look like it's
following you then seem that weird I
recall that Google Maps could get a
decent ground photo at the time so just
add Photoshop to that and you'd have a
gimmick plus we knew it couldn't be a
virus App Store checks every app for
things like that before peddling it the
only thing I found legitimate ly off
about it at the time was that it was
both free and AD 'less her explanation
of it sounded pretty cool to me so I
asked Sarah to help me download it on my
phone she told me that while my old
hand-me-down flip phone did have
something like an app store it most
likely didn't have mom
didn't stop her from looking though Sara
was a good sister she really could have
told me just to get out of her hair
but she almost took the time out of her
day for me packing my lunch playing with
me bringing me to r-rated movies that I
was clearly too young for I was lucky to
have her as a legal guardian when our
parents went away I was too young to
process at all when it happened but mom
and dad died from a head-on collision
with a drunk driver Sara took care of me
is my legal guardian up until I moved
out for college
God knows where I be if she didn't after
some prodding she found the app which
was a surprise to both of us it was
obvious that my phone didn't have any
kind of GPS but neither of us had even
thought about it until much much later
soon enough I received my first picture
I'll never understand the way Sara saw
the world that was her idea of cute the
photo was taken in my school's courtyard
with the creature I'd soon call Capone
sitting on one of the benches he could
barely see him but there he was covered
in his black matted fur with his knife
like claws a set of blank pure white
eyes and that face which was merely a
skull belonging to some kind of large
Beast looking directly at us with that
large wolfish grin I gave the phone back
to Sara telling her how terrifying it
was and that I didn't want the messages
anymore
she just jokingly punched my shoulder
saying home don't be such a baby it's
too cute look how happy is to meet you
I looked at his face his wide grin
specifically I have to admit I laughed
at that it was just the sheer wrongness
of that statement that made me listen to
the next I'm sure he'll grow on you
eventually tell you what if you can put
up with him for one whole week we'll go
see that movie you wanted to see if he
still gives you nightmares we'll delete
it if you end up liking it we'll laugh
about it later deal I looked at the
picture again
it appeared that getting a photo where
every now and then was the extent that
this was going to go to and looking at
in hindsight I probably would have kept
it on for next to nothing if she really
wanted me to so I agree
Sarah was ecstatic after that and
assured me that I wouldn't regret it
while showing me some of her own
pictures she only had three so far
wanted her office one at the park and
another on the road we lived on each
picture containing her own clearly
visible entity I must have looked
nervous or something because she
suggested that I named mine like she did
with her Cassandra I thought about it
for a bit let me make something clear
though because it seems to come up
whenever I tell people this I didn't
name my Moloch poem because of the
incident with my parents I didn't even
know that mom and dad's arrest involved
alcohol at the time
I named him after a history lesson I
found amusing in school where people's
fears got the best of them and as my
teacher put it it ended up doing more
harm than good it was intended as a
reminder that I shouldn't be making the
same mistake I saw that of light in this
whole thing after giving in a mock title
and thought that it wasn't gonna be that
bad I went to bed then my normal life
went on for just a little while longer I
continued to get pictures of Capone for
a while following me at school the bus
stop my street virtually anywhere I went
it wasn't until the third or fourth day
when I got called in from class I was
thinking I was in trouble for something
even if I didn't know what but as soon
as I saw Sarah that feeling was stifled
she looked very shaken the instant she
saw me she immediately yanked my arm and
brought me to the car Sarah was not
looking good at all she kept asking
questions about Capone things like if I
saw him or if I received any photos from
him with me and the images I haven't
checked anything for today but when I
checked there were two I remembered
exactly when and where those messages
were taken because during them have made
a mental note that I got some text from
Capone they've been sent as soon as
they've been taken Sarah knew that we
were being pursued by something she
probably had no idea by what they were
and I knew she had no idea how they were
doing it but she knew that they knew
where we lived she couldn't figure out
how to delete it she said she tried
everything but couldn't find a way to
get it off she couldn't even find where
they happened I'm not even sure what we
were planning to do but before we could
even fully plan a course of action I got
another text Sara froze and stared at me
as if to say don't look at it if I
didn't I could have had a semi-normal
life right now it would have been over
the news within a week and we would have
known but I did it I opened the phone
and there we were just sitting there
with that fear stricken look on her face
the photo was clearly taken from the
hood of a moving car giving us a clear
view of what was behind us
he took up most of the backseat and
towered over me we both turned around
preparing to scream at the monstrosity
behind us but when we did the seat was
empty they didn't know what was
happening or what to make of it but we
felt that the only thing to do is run
away abandoning the car we hastily
ditched the car ran the rest of the way
to the apartment and locked the door
behind us we locked ourselves in the
bathroom and waited we just stayed there
even when we got a message from
Cassandra or Capone Sara would scream at
them asking why they were following us
and begged for us to be left alone
we felt helpless against them all we
felt we could do is just sit in the
bathroom and hope they would go away the
room felt like our only safe haven until
we were exposed to them for too long
Sara started to panic she kept saying
that she kept seeing one of them behind
her I wasn't seeing it though I was more
concerned about trying to calm her down
by telling her that maybe they weren't
really there than I was about seeing
Capone in the mirror I convinced Sara
that we needed to leave the room out of
necessity we couldn't stay in the
apartment forever and if they wanted to
get to us they would have done so
already
we called the police and here we are we
both got help but I was the lucky one
everyone's case was different in terms
of interaction but for me Capone was
always in a mirror or some reflective
thing large enough to show him he was
predictable and I could find ways to
block him out when I needed it I learned
how to expect Capone and after a while
he kind of grow on me
I used to have a makeshift curtain that
I would pull over the mirrors when I
didn't want to see him but I started
using that curtain less and less as time
went on Capone always seemed to try and
interact with me even if I didn't
understand what he was trying to say
most of the time I started the Greek
Capone with a casual wave as I passed by
him from the living room mirror and
eventually he started to wave back he
kind of became a constant companion to
me and I just did took a poem just as he
adjusted to me my case wasn't as severe
as Sarah's she saw Cassandra everywhere
she looked around every corner just out
of sight over her while she slept
Sarah took her own life two years ago I
wanted to blame the malos for it but I
can't
following the person who looks at their
messages is just what they do now every
time I see Capone I'm reminded in a
puzzle what I did in the car that day I
knew I shouldn't have picked up that
text if I didn't she would still be here
it was almost four hours since Williams
started writing but he almost felt
relieved he's never actually told anyone
about this in such detail before the
majority of what happened was kept
between himself and Capone
he looked up to the creature in the
mirror from across the room for a few
seconds as it gave the old familiar wave
William was silent for a minute staring
at Capone and then back to his papers he
felt the need to make one last point but
then again how would I have known I
don't know who made the malos or why I
don't even know if anyone actually made
the app many things like it have been
created naturally or have been given
some kind of anomaly out of sheer chance
it would make so much sense if some
physical thing was to blame but there's
none
I can legitimately find not on the
Mallos not on me just on chance what's
what's with the blank expressions oh you
don't know about acid right new AI very
state of the art here at the foundation
we're developing new technology
constantly to deal with new threats
sometimes automatically acid really
helps with that but it has a multitude
of uses I'm not the technical guy I'm
gonna be mainly using him for speech
synthesis oh if you don't know acid
stands for anomalous containment
intelligence database I'm just the level
3 researcher who gets to use it anyway
I think that about does it for today
thank you very much for listening if
indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to albino Neku
James Saba Andre bishop Jax Merrick
Pablo ice 917 Burlington the cat
Justin day researcher bull Vere Pierce M
Hamlin Curie kuma white crew Nicholas
geum's vu Jack Bryce and Billy my
archive curator Nikki cootie tench the
Android slump god quartz 5 6 3 i'm tree
hero thank you all so much for your
support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well as it patreon.com forward
slash the volga thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]